take a look at this music box for our
first case study so I placed it on the
glass of the scanner and it looks pretty
good but as I look carefully which I
hope you'll do when you try this sort of
stuff with your work there are a couple
of things that I'm not thrilled with
first of all we're seeing some writing
on the barrel looking closer it appears
to be numbers and letters that's not
great our eyes go straight to letters
and numbers and they basically attract
our eye and actually become a
distraction from the image as far as I'm
concerned so I'm not happy with that and
I'm also not thrilled with the
positioning of the turning mechanism
let's call it a stem somehow it doesn't
feel composed properly so what I simply
did was I plated a bit so that the
barrel no longer shows the writing and I
turned the stem so that it landed in a
better composed image I've been thinking
about composition all my professional
life so see if you can agree with me on
this decision so I started thinking
about what difference it would make if
we change the orientation of the device
on the scanner now remember the light
and sensor travel only in one direction
we have no control over that so in this
first image the barrel of the music box
is parallel to the light source in the
next image I decided to rotate the music
box 90 degrees that is perpendicular to
the light source
here's that image take a look at the two
side-by-side and observe the difference
I'll let you think about that for a bit
right so you see the first image made
with the barrel oriented parallel to the
light source has a significant highlight
whereas the one captured perpendicular
to the light source has no highlight if
I sat down for a bit and tried to
anticipate all these results by drawing
arrows from light sources and
reflections and all that I might have
been able to anticipate what
differences would be in advance but I
would prefer to just discover experiment
with it just as I hope you'll do with
your own material I wonder what it would
look like if I oriented the device about
45 degrees to the light source what do
you think will be the results take a
moment you can even stop the video if
you'd like to okay ready
here we go nothing very important here
I'm afraid but the point is to
experiment with your material remember
you don't have control of your light
source with a scanner as you will with
your camera so at the very least take
advantage of what you do have control
over and in this case it's the placement
of your device here you're seeing this
incredible animal which is called a u
Plec tella which lives in the sea
this is his skeleton made out of silica
now when you take a careful look you can
see that two shrimp are living within
this guy and what can be called a
symbiotic relationship which is very
interesting tangential but quite
interesting ok so I put this
3-dimensional skeleton on the flatbed
scanner covered it with black velvet and
took a very high-rez scan I think it was
something like 1 gig file which is
pretty high the black velvet becomes the
background of the image right now watch
as we zoom into the image we start
seeing this magnificent structure that
nature is somehow able to produce those
fibers measure about 50 micron so I'm
quite serious about seeing things of
very fine structure if in fact once
again you capture at a high enough
resolution ok here's our final case
study for this particular tutorial it's
about a two and a half centimeter device
which once again I place on the scanner
for this I thought it'd be fun to show
you how I get some of these things in
the mail I made a quick image with my
phone camera to show you what I start
with and eventually wind up with I
thought it would be
interesting for you you can do this you
can see things that don't look so great
at the beginning and imagine ways of
creating an image that is publishable
take a hard look at your device as I'm
doing here try to look at it as if you
were looking at it for the first time
which I know is not easy but that's the
trick you might even think about
focusing on getting a cover image for
your submission that's where my thinking
was on this device since the article was
already accepted for publication
so here the image I made was about 374
Meg's and you can see as we zoom into
the image the nice detail in the device
again when you capture at a high enough
resolution on your scanner you can see
these details so when you think about
cover designs for example think about
cropping and formatting for the cover in
the end it turned out that for a cover
submission I did wind up using a camera
on this stereomicroscope this is what I
made with that equipment I thought I was
getting more clarity with the microscope
but frankly when I compare that to a few
months later as I record this tutorial
the scanned image looks pretty good and
maybe I was in a bit of overkill mode
these are the kinds of decisions you'll
have to make for your own work maybe you
have an opinion about which is better
take a look by the way in the end in
this case it didn't matter much we
didn't get the cover but at least I was
able to show you another example